as it is i've
i don't really respect the boundary of
architecture anyway
you know i i came into architecture in
an
unconventional way and i sort of resist
the idea that it's a separate thing
anyway
and i feel it's stitched in and part of
its problem has been
this idea that it is something else the
the idea that there's aeronautics and
astronautics and biological engineering
and um data systems and society that
they
why shouldn't they all have the same
kind of ambition that might be
associated with
uh with the design of city and place and
buildings and why shouldn't they have
the same
uh sense of overarching vision
i mean it's been interesting i've been
rereading some le corbusier
uh recently the the famous swiss french
uh master of modernism but he
is proudly using the word engineering
saying the architect is the engineer of
this
and the engine and the machines the
engineers but then he equally and
another thing
says that would just be near engineering
you know and you you kind of go hang on
you've got to
it's engineering an incredible thing or
you've actually you've got your little
pecking order and you're above the
engineer are you
and then you think back up to like the
british
amazing creator isambard kingdom brunel
who made beauty as well as pioneering
new ways of making
ships and trains and stations
and structures and bridges and you know
saw it as one interlinked area and the
i think the decoupling of how you feel
emotion has been a stupid one and i
think we'll look back
at the idea that this was a separate
thing
uh when in decades or centuries or i
feel it now
is that that was that was a wrong wrong
thinking
and so i suppose i see it it all
stitching together and it's it's
obviously easier and tidier to break
things into departments and separate
them
but i i see it as one interlinked thing
so i
i'm envious of the the big soup
of mit with all the lovely floating
bubbles of ingredients that are there um
that are um are part of the same soup
we will take soup as a compliment